hey 42 here meet the most audacious
granddad's this side of a Sunday roast
the so called grandpa gang pulled off
the largest burglary in English history
in April 2015 the group of four men
robbed a safety-deposit building in the
world-famous Hatton Garden area of
London well known for its jewelry and
diamond stops the gang hobbled away with
40 million pounds worth of diamonds
jewelry and cash but let's not all get
too excited these weren't your average
grandpa's who got overly frustrated in
bowls and decided to plan a grand
larceny powder-blue
every member the gang was a seasoned
criminal had a long rap list of armed
robbers between them
hey with life expectancies rising the
longer the retirement age you can't
blame them for not wanting to hang get
up just yet the ringleader and
mastermind of the plot is a man cocaine
parcel the group originally settled on
mr. pink but he was having none of that
other members of the group were
nicknamed mr. ginger mr. strong mr.
Montana the James the tall man and the
old man this sounds like a movie just
waiting to happen it was a well
orchestrated ambitious and daring plan
or four topped by a group of company
granddad's in a pub in Islington
seriously though in slight the cast of
snapchat returned for a reunion 30 years
later the youngest of the group was 48
years old whilst arrest her in their 50s
60s and 70s the eldest being ringleader
brain reader of 76
better yet rhyme reader actually used
the senior citizens for spots to get to
the scene of the crime you've got to
admire these gents - NASA - it believed
11 men were involved in the planning of
the burglary in total what only four of
the men actually carried out the fact
those four also happened to be the
eldest and most experienced of the group
so how did they do it well it was no
small feat the audacious plan was three
years in the making to start the
burglary was perfectly timed to take
place on the longest weekend a four-day
holiday in the you
this gave them four full days to perform
the fact when they knew the safety
deposit boxes would not be mount the
main man Buzzle whose identity is still
unknown was an insider who the police
believed either worked at or had strong
connections with Hatton Garden
safe-deposit Limited for months or even
years before the robbery took place the
four men approached a building disguised
as garbage collectors pushing really
bins the bins of course having a double
use as they were also used to transport
the stolen goods out of the building
afterwards the gang then used Buzzle x'
insider knowledge to enter the building
by the elevator
they then climbed down to the basement
and drill through the thick concrete
wall of the underground vault using an
industrial diamond tipped power drill
and then they robbed the vault no not
quite
remember this was a sophisticated
elderly gentleman's caper
this wasn't a smash and grab on there
certainly not in the hood so they took
their sweet time after a full day of
drilling the men were to exhaust it to
carry on and were foiled by a metal
cabinet inside the vault which they
couldn't manage to shift so they all
went home for a cuppa and a crossword
presumably then returns the next day
entered the vault and stole 73 deposit
boxes containing 14 million pounds worth
of fine gemstones and luxury goods but
the escapade wasn't without its blunders
the daring gold gents actually triggered
the alarm
during the first day of the robbery so
surely that was game over
well no the security guards came but
declared it was a false alarm and left
like hell Gavin I was a close one we can
only imagine the gang were marked before
continuing along their merry way this
was a proper old-school caper though the
gang used walkie-talkies to communicate
to avoid being tracked by the police
you're not going to find this like using
burners or fancy Internet VPNs so what
became of this bunch of old-timers well
the gang may have gotten away with many
robbed
in the past but their old age must have
caught up to them as they left a few
clues which eventually led to the arrest
of all but one individual involved in
the robbery one of the police detectives
biggest clues was that gang member
daniel Jones bought a hydraulic pump in
a hardware shop in Twickenham fifteen
miles from the scene of the crime but
the silly book only when it gave his
real name and address to the sales
assistant all in all the gang may have
just been a bit out of their depth and
out of practice with all the newfangled
technology and techniques at the police
now used to track down criminals they
were definitely trying to brush up on
all those the police found a forensics
for dummies book in one of the men's
apartments he just couldn't make this
stuff up so who was the one man who did
get away it was of course the infamous
the incredible the main man at the heart
of it all
buzzer whilst all his cohorts are now
serving time to this day the police
still have no idea as to the identity or
whereabouts of Buzzle what they do know
is that wherever he is he has a cool 10
million pounds worth of diamonds on
rumor has it he used his newfound wealth
to start a hotel in Torquay with his
wife Sybil well I guess we'll never know
thanks for hunting
welcome to the weirdest city in Alaska
Whittier
but Whittier is the city that forgot how
to city because it is home to just 220
people and they all live in one building
could we actually make Mars into a place
where humanity could survive could we
breathe could we grow food are there any
good bars